there's nothing that scales faster than
paid ads because if we're doing it right
in the ideal scene you put a dollar in
you get a dollar back and then some and
then you can take that extra money and
buy more customers with it so you bought
one customer and had some profit so then
you can buy two customers have some
profit buy four customers have some
profit so quickly getting customers is
no longer the bottleneck or the
constraint in the business and so the
idea is to find the winning ad scaling
the hell out of that one and then you
don't need to worry about the row eyes
or your marketing budget it's a get out
of Gil free card that you can use for
the rest of your life